[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in allen an diesem
samstag im juli wir werden uns auf eine
lange zeit der krisen einstellen müssen
da sind sich praktisch alle beobachter
einig die kommende woche wird für
deutschland im zeichen der frage stehen
wie können wir reagieren auf die
drohende energieknappheit und wer zahlt
den preis der krieg geht unterdessen
auch am
129 tag weiter die lage im umkämpften
osten der ukraine bleibt ernst was für
die menschen dort bedeutet zeigt
christiane hoffmann
als sieger passieren diese
tschetschenischen kämpfern offenbar in
den trümmern der umkämpften stadt ließ
chance das video kursiert am abend in
sozialen netzwerken die als besonders
brutal geltenden tschetschenen schwenken
fahnen mit dem bild ihres anführers
kadir auf und behaupten sie hätten die
stadt komplett eingenommen das
ukrainische militär dementiert das
spricht nur von schweren kämpfen in
lizenz von völliger zerstörung berichten
geflüchtete die es in letzter minute aus
lisse pence heraus geschafft haben
ich war bis zuletzt dort bis das
kulturzentrum zerstört wurde es gab
viele opfer unter den trümmern sie haben
mich da herausgeholt
[Musik]
die stadt existiert praktisch nicht mehr
sie ist so gut wie ausgelöscht
von einer russischen vernichtungs
strategie spricht auch der gouverneur
von lufthansa die besatzer hörten nicht
auf städte und dörfer rund um les sons
zu beschießen an tag 129 des krieges
konzentrieren sich die kampfhandlungen
auf die ost ukraine die städte donetsk
und ließ sind weitgehend zerstört nun
sind vor allem die städte aktiv niculae
von bach mit ziele russischer angriffe
aber auch der urlaubsort sehr tief das
südlich von odessa wurde beschossen
am tag nach dem angriff auf ein wohnhaus
ins archiv gesuche rettungskräfte in den
trümmern nach überlebenden und toten
mitten in der nacht waren mehrere
raketen in dem neunstöckigen wohnhaus
eingeschlagen
jeder der im haus war ist wahrscheinlich
tot unsere nachbarin war ein guter
mensch sie ist in meinen armen gestorben
ich möchte sagen es gab hier kein
militär oder etwas ähnliches in diesem
gebäude es gab keine kämpfe nur
friedliche zivilisten haben hier gelebt
glückliche friedliche menschen
mindestens 21 bewohner seien bei dem
angriff gestorben sagt präsident
selensky
ich möchte betonen das ist vorsätzliche
zielgerichteter russische terror das
sind keine fehler oder zufälliger
raketenbeschuss und dann meldete sich am
abend noch der russland nahe nachbar der
ukraine der belarussische präsident
lukaschenko behauptet sein militär habe
ukrainischen raketenbeschuss vereitelt
legte aber keine beweise vor er drohte
der ukraine und dem westen mit einem
eingreifen in den krieg sollte belarus
angegriffen werden
dran bleiben auch wenn ein ereignis aus
den ganz großen schlagzeilen
verschwunden ist auch das ist
journalismus gerade das ist journalismus
verheerendes erdbeben im osten von
afghanistan das war die eilmeldung sieht
die welt aufgeschreckt hat vor etwas
mehr als einer woche von über 1000
todesopfern war die rede zehntausende
haben ihr dach über dem kopf verloren
ein zdf team war in der betroffenen
region unterwegs und zeigt ein land das
unter der herrschaft der islamisten
versucht mit einer naturkatastrophe
fertig zu werden jörg brase berichtet
die schweren fälle haben sie nach ghasni
gebracht in die provinzhauptstadt
120 kilometer entfernt zehn tage nach
dem beben haben sie die lage hier im
regionalkrankenhaus von organen griff 80
patienten haben sie insgesamt verarztet
die
medikamente und alle anderen
behandlungsmittel haben wir rechtzeitig
bekommen können alle ärzte hier tun ihr
bestes bislang jedenfalls haben wir
keinen mangel an medikamenten erleben
müssen
weil es in den städten straßen gibt und
wasser und strom in den dörfern in den
bergen aber die vom beben zerstört
wurden gibt es das nicht bis hierher
vorzudringen ist ein abenteuer für unser
team genauso wie für die lkw der
hilfsorganisationen die hier oben
verteilt stationen aufbauen
diese gegend ist weit entfernt von
entwickelten und zivilisierten gebieten
bis zur nächsten größeren stadt ist es
eher bereit in dieser entlegenen dörfer
erste hilfe und nahrungsmittel zu
bringen ist eine herausforderung
die hilfe wird von örtlichen behörden
verteilt unter aufsicht der taliban die
kriterien der verteilung seien
intransparent die taliban übten einfluss
darauf aus wer die güter am ende bekomme
kritisieren die vereinten nationen in
einer dringlichkeitssitzung verurteilte
der un-menschenrechtsrat gestern zu dem
auch die anhaltende unterdrückung von
frauen
die de facto regierung versprach bei
meinem besuch im märz ihre
menschenrechts verpflichtungen
einzuhalten so weit sie mit der scharia
vereinbar seien trotz dieser zusagen
sehen wir den anhaltenden ausschluss von
frauen und mädchen vom öffentlichen
leben und ihre systematische
unterdrückung
in der hauptstadt kabul hielt die
taliban-führung eine versammlung von
3.000 islamischen gelehrten ab
kamerateams waren dabei nicht zugelassen
frauen auch nicht zu diesem thema gab es
auf der pressekonferenz mal wieder nur
vage versprechungen
die sache mit der schulausbildung für
mädchen ist schwierig und muss von der
regierung gelöst werden dabei muss sie
die forderungen der menschen und die
bedürfnisse zukünftiger generationen
berücksichtigen wenn es dann so weit ist
müssen erst alle geistlichen gelehrten
zustimmen dann muss es umgesetzt werden
und das wird sicher etwas dauern
dies sind einige der wenigen bilder von
mädchen und frauen die unser team in all
den tagen machen konnte wie lange werden
diese mädchen warten müssen bis sie
einen schulabschluss machen dürfen und
wie lange wird es dauern bis auch ihre
schule wieder aufgebaut ist
wahrscheinlich noch sehr lang zumal in
dieser entlegenen armen gegend wo das
beben wütete und die taliban seit langem
schon das sagen haben
nachrichten jetzt in der übersicht an
diesem samstag mit johanna der präsident
der bundesnetzagentur befürchtet einen
totalausfall der gaslieferungen aus
russland und hat zum gas sparen
aufgerufen die frage sei ob aus der
bevorstehenden technischen wartung von
nord stream 1 eine zitat länger
andauernde politische wartung werde das
sagte müller der funke mediengruppe haus
und wohnungsbesitzer forderte er dazu
auf ihre gasheizungen zeitnah warten und
effizienter einstellen zu lassen dies
könne den gasverbrauch um 15 bis 10 bis
15 prozent senken
fast ein jahr nach der flutkatastrophe
im aartal sind heute zahlreiche
betroffene in mainz auf die straße
gegangen um für einen schnelleren
wiederaufbau zu demonstrieren laut
initiatoren ist eines der hauptprobleme
dass die staatlichen hilfen nur
schleppend ausgezahlt werden bei der
katastrophe mitte juli 2021 waren in
rheinland-pfalz 134 menschen getötet
worden tausende häuser wurden beschädigt
und unbewohnbar
die hochansteckende afrikanische
schweinepest breitet sich in deutschland
weiter aus zum ersten mal wurde die
tierseuche nun in niedersachsen
nachgewiesen in einem mastbetrieb im
emsland alle knapp 1800 tiere in den
befallenen betrieb müssen jetzt gekeult
werden außerdem wird eine zehn kilometer
sperrzone eingerichtet wie das virus
übertragen wurde ist unklar die
schweinepest ist für menschen
ungefährlich
in libyen hat das gewaltsame proteste
gegen schlechte lebensbedingungen und
politischen stillstand gegeben im osten
des landes stürmten demonstrierende das
parlament und setzen ist teilweise in
brand libyen ist seit dem sturz von
langzeitherrscher gaddafi im jahr 2011
von chaos und gewalt geprägt zwei
rivalisierende regierungen und
bewaffnete milizen ringen um die macht
peter joseph lenné der legendäre
landschaftsarchitekt wäre entsetzt wenn
er sein werk heute sehen könnte im
schlosspark sanssouci in potsdam geht
die sorge um
bäume die vor bald 200 jahren dort
gepflanzt wurden kämpfen ums überleben
mehr als zwei drittel von ihnen sind
bereits geschädigt die klimakrise hat
die weltberühmten parks der
preußenkönige erreicht ein welterbe am
wendepunkt wie katrin lindner zeigt
songs i das heißt ohne sorge so hat
einst friedrich der große sein sommer
schloss genannt inmitten der 300 hektar
großen parkanlage kann man wirklich all
seine sorgen vergessen
doch nicht parkleiter reif kreuz denn es
herrscht dürre im gartenparadies alte
bäume sterben ab die trockenheit lässt
die gärtner an ihre grenzen stoßen schon
seit april bewässern sie doch das reicht
nicht wir haben in der obersten schicht
ein bisschen feuchtigkeit noch aber dann
nach unten rein meter meter fünfzig ist
trockenheit dass das das können wir
nicht leisten da haben wir nicht das
wasser dazu und auch nicht die
technischen möglichkeiten um diese bäume
so intensiv zu bessern die alten bäume
haben ihre wurzeln an den
grundwasserstand der vergangenen zeiten
angepasst aber mit dem fünften dreier in
folge geht er immer weiter zurück nur
viel mehr regen könnte helfen doch
wetterexperten haben wenig hoffnung
das niederschlagsdefizit dass wir
mittlerweile aufgebaut haben entspricht
fast dem niederschlag eines jahres in
der region berlin-brandenburg und wer
muss die zukunft angucken dann ist
eigentlich unentschieden wieder
niederschlag sicher wickelt die neuesten
szenarien generationen zeigt er ein
trockenes zukünftiges klima park songs
sie mit seinen schlössern gehört zum
weltkulturerbe
die bäume sind teil des kunstwerks
geschaffen von generationen von gärtnern
noch heute kommen nachfahren der
königlichen hof gärtner zusammen nach
songs sie in diesem jahr um rosen zu
taufen
ich hoffe dass dieses ganze wissen was
hier vorhanden ist und weiter gegeben
wird für die zukunft ausreichen wird und
man ausreichend mittel zur verfügung
stellt dass die bäume überleben werden
der historische garten ist auch ein
labor wissenschaftler unterstützen die
gärtner von heute bei der suche nach
widerstandsfähigeren pflanzen
bodenverbesserung und der optimalen
bewässerung
im grunde genommen wissen wir seit zehn
fünfzehn jahren dass der gärtner beruf
ein beruf der sorge ist denn wir müssen
wirklich die klima anpassungsstrategien
durchsetzen und wir werden das auch
hinbekommen genauso wie sein vorgänger
der große garten architekt peter joseph
lenné er hatte auch seine liebe not mit
dem märkischen sand boten und trotzdem
ist dieses einmalige garten kunstwerk
entstanden linie hat das was wir hier
haben ja nie so gesehen das muss man
sich auch mal verborgenen augen halten
da war was der aufbau wir sind im
umbruch und so fangen sie wieder ganz
klein an mit bäumen die hoffentlich dem
klima gewachsen sind das klima hat sich
geändert das ziel der gärtner nicht ihre
gartenkunst für die nachwelt zu erhalten
ja welche buchalla verlust da droht
zeigt auch die tatsache dass viele der
baumgruppen gerade jetzt ihr alter und
ihre größe erreicht haben um exakt das
bild zu ergeben dass die
landschaftsarchitekten eins im sinn
hatten und ihnen jetzt das wasser
ausgeht
nochmal hanna hier bei uns in der
sendung mit dem samstag sport und da gab
es heute keine guten nachrichten für die
deutschen reiter beim chio in aachen im
grand prix spezial wurde isabell werth
disqualifiziert weil am maul ihres
pferdes blut entdeckt wurde die deutsche
equipe vergab so die chance auf den sieg
in der nationenwertung
und in der vielseitigkeit verloren
michael jung und chipmunk nachträglich
den ersten platz weil sie ein hindernis
nicht korrekt überquert hatten der titel
ging dann am teamkollegin sandra
auffarth
der niederländer fabio jacobs nun hat
die zweite etappe der tour de france in
dänemark gewonnen
spektakulär heute die strecke über 200
25 kilometer die auch über den großen
belt führte auf der brücke dann ein
massensturz dabei auch betroffenen
auftaktsieger es lampard das rennen
entschied sich im schlusssprint nach
jacobson überquerte der belgier bart van
aart die ziellinie der nun das gelbe
trikot übernimmt
zu den lottozahlen an diesem samstag die
lauten 7 89 20
37 45 superzahl 7 alle angaben ohne
gewähr
fehlen noch die wetteraussichten morgen
ist es zunächst meist sonnig am
nachmittag gibt es im nordwesten
einzelne schauer im schwarzwald
vereinzelt gewitter an der nordsee
werden 22 grad erreicht sonst sind es 26
bis 32 grad in den kommenden tagen gibt
es in alpennähe teils kräftige schauer
und gewitter am montag auch im äußersten
norden sonst ist es warm und freundlich
die höchstwerte liegen zwischen 17 und
28 grad und
damit vom gesamten heute-journal team
einen angenehmen abend nach 1
[Musik]